pinkey malenky is creating a lot of buzz
on netflix and even like the new kids
show is Netflix is attempt at creating a
likable cartoon similar to the amazing
world of gumball but is it really that
great most cartoons seem to have a lot
of adult or immature humor and pinky
malinki isn't that different stay tuned
to find out more about the show get some
examples of weird and inappropriate
jokes and check out what the critics
think of pinky malinki whoa weird about
pinky malinki pinky malenky is the
newest netflix original show of course
it's only new for some people because
others have been waiting a long time to
see it come to life
pinky malenky was actually meant to be
broadcast on nickelodeon before it
finally aired on Netflix it went through
several production delays it was
actually officially announced in 2016
but it took three years for it to
finally take off the wacky fast-paced
cartoon focuses on pinky malinki the
talking and walking hot dog who creates
YouTube style vlogs with his friends his
voice might sound familiar to you it
belongs to Lucas Grabeel known for his
role as Ryan Evans in High School
Musical pinky the hot dog has
surprisingly human characters around him
like his grandmother
Kathy malinki who's played by Miranda
Richardson you might know her from
playing Rita Skeeter in the one and only
Harry Potter icarly Smith and kress
plays JJ Jameson one of pinky's best
friends
other characters include Babs missus
malenky mr. malenky and many many more
every character is part of pinky's crazy
adventures pinky malenky is actually
very similar to the amazing world of
gumball the two shows actually share a
creator Chris Garbett worked on both
shows which explains the strange humor
that takes some time to get used to
before we check out some examples of the
strange humor you'll find on the show
let's see how pinky malenky was
perceived by the critics we are going to
reverse-engineer Poppins
science Common Sense Media states that
the show features a lot of absurdity
without real world sensibility there
appears to be a lot of name-calling
along with making fun of pinky's actual
hot dog look
although Common Sense Media praises
different animation styles it states
that the storyline is slightly
underwhelming pinky tends to do a lot of
his stuff from his house where he's
often supervised by his parents to
Snyder calm says the piece of the show
is definitely quick but what would
attract the kids are the bold and
colorful animations
however they pointed out that the show's
strange sense of humor might be hard to
translate to the kids and to the parents
the review also states the vlog format
brings more style rather than substance
to the show another review comes from
the review geek.com
which also highlights the quick peace of
the show although the characters get
quickly established the review states
the show then becomes a jumbled mess of
different jokes styles of humor and
tonally inconsistent narratives the
review also notes that the show features
toilet humor as well as jokes about
corporate greed and capitalism which
would definitely go over the kids heads
according to the review geek the above
factors make the show a bit difficult to
recommend so let's check out some of
these jokes the critics are talking
about shall we the theme song
we're going to start with the theme song
because let's be honest it's the first
thing we hear sure it's funny and it's
upbeat but is it really made for kids
it's a pretty simple and quick theme
song the song basically introduces
pinkie blinky as someone who always
looks at the bright side of life nothing
wrong with that right
but then the singers just start
screaming Wiener over and over again
sure it might seem funny to kids but we
have a feeling no parent wants their
child to sing that song imagine a kid
singing this in public even some of the
YouTube comments aren't sure of the show
or this song one user posted that this
seems like a strange show another joke
that breakfast will never be the same
again we have a feeling kids will look
at eating hotdogs in an entirely
different way after this let's just hope
the theme song doesn't get stuck in
their heads parents might have a lot of
trouble getting their kid to stop
singing about wieners a hotdog the
inappropriate joke start the moment you
see the
scenes of the first episode the pilot
episode of any cartoon show is always a
hit or miss it's when the characters get
briefly introduced but it might take a
few episodes before they're fully
developed what we do know about pinkie
malenky is that he's a hot dog he
literally says it himself in the trailer
of the show he's a hot dog but what's
inappropriate is the way he poses during
his introduction pinkies using
suggestive poses to show his audience
that he really is a hot dog as in he
thinks he's hot
aka totally gorgeous that's definitely
not the language kids should be using
especially not when they're describing
themselves or anyone else not to mention
those poses seem way too mature for a
character who is clearly still just in
school this joke is pretty obvious but
in our opinion it shouldn't really be
meant for kids way too gruesome the
trailer has plenty of moments that
already showcase just how crazy this
cartoon might be in fact it can even be
traumatic to see like this moment which
clearly shows pinky going through
something extreme we feel you buddy we
all want to do this sometimes he's
waiting in front of the principal's
office and he pretty much feels how we
all feel in school then pinky randomly
takes off his skin and reveals the
so-called inside of a hotdog
seriously we weren't prepared for this
moment he pulls off his skin which
includes eyes and mouth this guy has
some serious aggression he needs to let
out from his school environment
either way this might just be a little
bit too much for kids to even see isn't
it scary just to look at him like this
of course he returns to normal just a
second later but that doesn't mean that
this so-called joke won't leave some
kids totally traumatized
we don't even peel a real-life hotdog to
see what's inside icebucketchallenge
Netflix YouTube channel has plenty of
extra pinky malenky Clips like this one
which focuses on describing pinky's
ultimate year similar to YouTube rewind
the clip also features a couple of
seconds of the popular ice bucket
challenge from 2014 well a weird
variation of the ice bucket challenge
you know from the internet the two
characters are basically shown doing an
ice bucket challenge but it
appears to be completely different from
the challenge you might know although
this was definitely supposed to be a
joke it mocks what the ice bucket
challenge was originally about anyways
in case you don't remember the challenge
was created by the ALS Association in
order to promote awareness of the motor
neuron disease it involves dumping a
bucket of ice and water over a person's
head nominating another person to do it
and encouraging people to donate to the
cause young kids that would watch pinky
malinki definitely would not even know
about the ice bucket challenge since it
happened so long ago hopefully none of
them think this is the actual challenge
correct we're not really sure what's
happening in those few seconds but this
joke didn't translate very well
hopefully the kids understand the actual
meaning behind the ice bucket challenge
weird social media humor you can pretty
much find strange jokes in every single
episode so let's focus on those that the
kids wouldn't really understand or get
the wrong idea like this weird social
media humor moment pinky malenky also
has his own YouTube channel in real life
which was created back in 2016 when the
show was first pitched
it features short clips with a somewhat
edgy sense of humor like this clip in
which pinky freaks out because JJ
unfollowed him on social media like
seriously he freaks out and then there's
JJ on his phone did you notice that it
has a pear on its back instead of the
popular Apple but back to the point
JJ casually replies that he didn't and
follow him pinky then goes back to
normal and just says that he thought he
did that's it
that's the clip we have a feeling
younger kids that don't really use
social media won't really know how to
translate this clip not to mention they
shouldn't use social media in the first
place hello police in this second
episode of season 1 pinky volunteers at
an animal shelter it's actually kind of
sweet to show that you can have bonds
with animals from a shelter this episode
definitely encourages volunteering which
definitely heads in the right direction
pinky ends up bringing home theater the
cat without even consulting his parents
who clearly heated the cat in reality
kids should absolutely ask their parents
before doing anything like this not to
mention that it's hard to volunteer at
an animal shelter if you're as youngest
he is anyways pinkie also talks back to
his parents in a pretty rude way when
they're trying to convince him that
Peter the cat isn't right for him but
that wasn't even the joke pinky decides
he's going to prove that Peter and him
belong together and that's when a random
cop who we're assuming as Babs dad shows
up in pinky's room the cat pretty much
attacks everyone and soon we see Babs
his dad pretty much naked on a bed with
the rest of the kids they're obviously
hiding from the vicious cat who ripped
off dad's clothes but maybe that scene
is just a little bit inappropriate for
the kids to see strange language in the
13th episode of the first season we
learned that the kids play a weekly
role-playing game and they really seem
to be into it but things go a little bit
too far when we find out they also have
their own language pinkie reveals they
main 87 different words for blood why
would you even need that isn't that just
a little bit too gory for kids we also
see the characters grunt in their own
language and honestly it just looks a
bit violent we get that it's meant to be
funny but we have a feeling kids would
be just as freaked out as the bus-stop
lady seriously inventing a language like
that and using it in public while
intentionally scaring people is not okay
this is one of those moments that could
definitely give kids a wrong impression
we get it it's meant to be a joke but is
it really their language clearly scared
a stranger if this was realized that
stranger would be traumatized and the
kids would get in trouble we're sure you
can find questionable humor in every
single pinkie malinki episode despite
harsh criticism it's a show you
definitely have to get used to time will
tell how well pinky malinki will go down
with kids and whether the theme song
will get stuck in their heads who knows
you might be singing Weiner over and
over again soon you can now enjoy the
entire first season on Netflix make sure
you check it out for yourself best part
the show will definitely stick around as
season 2 is already in the works
and confirmed by Netflix despite the
harsh criticism the show will without a
doubt evolve and find its way into our
hearts just like gumball did what do you
think about pinky malenky are the jokes
too mature for kids
does the show teach the kids important
life lessons
is it just something that's not that
deep even like come let us know in the
comments section below and that's it for
our video don't forget to subscribe to
the things for more feel-good content
thanks for watching and see you next
time
[Music]